it's such a tricky one because I do feel
as a white South African no matter what
my political beliefs I need to be very
careful to you know through her any
stories because I certainly lived in a
glass house for Wow
so I mean it's been interesting to me
just to you know obviously there's a lot
of hypocrisy involved and a lot of kind
of blame game that's that's played but I
think to me it's a more interesting
thing in America of imagining America
likes to think of itself as being a
classless society and I think you know
race and class relief you know intersect
in America and so I think it's less
about race that I think the problem is
but more about an elite class in America
who've been whose needs have been
privileged for too long and and that has
sort of led the country into you know
it's difficult difficult times but I did
notice that as an undergraduate I was a
member of the African Students
Association and there was a very strange
relationship between the African
American student associations and the
African student associations and the
strange kind of I think each was
threatened by the other and the African
American so threatened by this
questioning of their own or theta-c by
the African Students Association and you
know sort of vice versa and so that was
just an interesting sort of dynamic that
I
you